I spent a lot of time looking at foreign
models actually chaired this year the
health governor's at the World Economic
Congress in Davos and I'm the current
chair of the International Federation of
health plans and that's health plans
from 80 countries around the world and
so I meet all the time with health plans
from from those other countries and I've
been looking hard to figure out which
attributes of those plans would fit in
the US and one of the things I've
learned from working with all those
countries is that every single one does
it a little differently so the model in
Germany looks a lot like the Netherlands
but it's not quite the same Austria
different than both those but quite
similar in fact the model that Governor
Schwarzenegger proposed in California
last year looks suspiciously like the
Austrian model the every country does it
slightly differently but if I were going
to pick a model that I think would
transplant well it's actually the Dutch
model I think the Dutch have done some
really good things and the thing that
they have added to their model more
recently is a risk adjuster between the
health plan so when the health plans go
out and recruit members and enroll
people the government in the end does a
an assessment who got the healthy people
who got the less healthy people and if
any health plan got a disproportionate
number of healthy people they have to
actually pay some money back into the
pool and any health plan got too many
sick people they get more money from the
pool and so what that does is strongly
encourage as we were saying earlier to
health plans to go after the sicker
people and do a really good job taking
your sick people because I know in the
end they get a risk adjuster from the
other plans that enrolled healthier
people so I think the Dutch model of
having a payroll deduction individual
choice health plans and then a risk
adjuster in the back end has a lot to
offer it's a federal model they
basically in the end of the year run the
core information about each health by
how many diabetics that they have how
many congestive heart failure patients
how many asthmatics they sort
the whole thing and then basically run a
formula and if you have enrolled a
disproportionate number of people with
those expensive diseases in a high level
of morbidity they increase your payment
or it's a low level decrease your
payment and actually we do that some
degree in this country on our Medicare
Advantage program there's already we
have a risk adjuster formula that works
in America it's a pretty good formula
it's not perfect but it's a lot better
than no formula and so we we already
have a history of doing that we could
could adapt to the Dutch model fairly
easy